on la connait c'est comique la voici
comédienne ouais si muriel robin la
vraie
madame bonsoir alors tout le monde en
parle
héroïne du nouveau film de mehdi charef
qui s'appelle marie line ce comme ses
roues dans garde à vue comme coluche
dans tchao pantin vous passer avec
succès du comics jeux du
programmatiquement fin au sérieux ça a
bien démarré
c'est bien oui c'est bien c'est
tellement inquiète la semaine dernière
non vraiment ça drôle de truc que j'ai
vécu je vais pas on entend parler de ça
le mercredi ont été déçus ça peu virtuel
mais puisque vous arrivez vous mettez
sur les champs elysées à deux heures de
l'après midi
j'hésitais g tournicoter qui a
finalement je suis allé on disait les
chiffres à oui c'est crevant un chacun
de vous répondre à une interview que ce
soit dans la presse ou dans là où la
télé ou à la radio
oui toujours c'est ma mère en parlant de
marilyn vous dites pour retrouver cette
dureté j'ai eu qu'à me souvenir
vous racontez votre enfance ça lui fait
quoi perdre quand même parce que quand
on touche pas elle gueule pas quand elle
a parlé lui il a parlé mais si
finalement je suis désolé raccourci que
je me comprendre mais c'est pas ma mère
mais c'est vrai que je connais la dureté
ouais ouais donc je n'ai pas eu à me
souvenir ce que c'est avait de la dureté
il y avait de la dureté autour de moi
quand j'étais enfant et j'en ai gardé
malheureusement c'est parce que je
préfère chez moi donc j'ai pu puiser là
dedans
évidemment le film oui et alors je la
trouvais blanche parle peu c'est un peu
comme dans le film
oui oui oui nous on se parle pas
beaucoup donc elle a dit qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit elle a dit vous avez
déclaré s'il ya vu un papa une maman
classique qui vous avez appelé mon bébé
chéri toute la journée
j'aurais été quelqu'un d'autre oui bah
oui évidemment je pars trop pris de
risque en disant ça ne l'est pas moi je
crois que voilà les parents c'est
extrêmement important voilà quand on
rencontre quelqu'un il faudra pas lui
demander que tu fais comme métier frais
dire qu'est ce que ta mère donc mer
qu'est ce que c'est dès qu'on prend cinq
minutes explique beaucoup de choses
donc si on pouvait s'attaquer au 21ème
siècle ou au mythe de l'amour maternel
ça serait intéressant c'est vrai quand
vous étiez petit quand vous allez
coucher chez des copines
affreusement étonné de voir que
finalement ils s'embrassent et le soir
on se paie cher et il se réveiller le
matin ils sont nouveaux pour donner jour
à 8 kg et ses amis ça me faisait oui
quand on connaît pas ça fait je pensais
que c'était c'était partout comme chez
moi quand je disais ils sont bizarres
ces gens s'ils viennent décembre ciel
matin à remettre ça y est on y pense
c'est encore plus bizarre qu'est ce
qu'on a c'est en gros c'était d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas en gros c'était le
rendement ces gens qui parce que la
jeunesse l'échelle à gateshead autre
chose à faire quand on connaît pas cessé
voilà on est étranger
c'est parce que j'ai mis tout ça dans
peut-être que je suis mais bien non je
crois à la charge des familles de
quelqu'un d'autre du kgb a mis deux mois